[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN FREY: Hello, I'm Dan Frey.
And I'm the faculty research
director at MIT's D lab.
I'm also principal investigator
for the Comprehensive
Initiative on Technology
Evaluation, which we
refer to by the acronym CITE.
The CITE program was
established in order
to assess and evaluate
technologies and products
so that we can better understand
which ones perform the best
and also which ones provide the
best value given the context.
And better information about
process and technologies
also helps us to best
implement those technologies
in an international
development setting.
Now, this topic is especially
important in machine learning.
We understand that these
exciting new technologies
can sometimes cause or else
propagate certain inequities
or biases.
And there are a
number of techniques
that are now emerging from
research community that
can help us to mitigate
those problems by adjusting
the algorithms or
else modifying data
sets in order to provide better,
more equitable, and more fair
outcomes.
Now, we hope that you'll
engage with us very deeply
in this course and that we'll be
able to provide knowledge that
can help you to better
implement these techniques
in your own
professional endeavors.
Thanks for joining
us in this course.
[MUSIC PLAYING]